what is chemistry
like does sand still count as chemistry
sure i mean as a chemist they can't
carry a chemist if i'm allowed a card i
don't know i don't know what i am most
days what is the card made of
what's the chemical composition of the
card
yeah so um what is chemistry well
chemistry is the thing that happens when
you bring electrons together and you
form bonds
so bonds well i say to people when they
talk about life elsewhere
and i just say well there's bonds
there's hope because bonds allow you to
get heterogeneity they allow you to
record those memories or at least on
earth um you could imagine uh
you know a stannis left lemtrey world
where you might have life emerging or
intelligence emerging before life that
may be something to on like solaris or
something but you know to get to
selection if you can form if atoms can
combine and form bonds those bonds
those atoms can bond to different
elements and those and those molecules
will have different identities and
interact with each other differently and
then you can start to have some degree
of causation or interaction
and then selection and then put and then
existence and then you you you go you go
up the kind of the path of complexity
and so at least on earth
as we know it there are there is a
sufficient pool of
available chemicals to start create
searching that combinatorial space of
bonds
so okay this is a really interesting
question let's let's lay it out so bonds
almost like cards we say there's bonds
there is uh
life there's intelligence there's
consciousness and what you just made me
realize
is um
those can emerge or let's put bonds
aside uh those can emerge in any order
that's that's really brilliant so
intelligence can come before life it's
like
pan psychists believe that consciousness
com i guess comes before
life
and before intelligence
so consciousness like permeates all
matter it's some kind of fabric of
reality okay so like within this
framework you can kind of arrange
everything but you need to have the
bonds
um that precedes everything else oh and
the other thing is selection
so like the mechanism of selection
that could
uh proceed see couldn't that proceed
bonds to whatever the house election so
i would say that there is an elegant
order to it that bonds
allow selection allows the emergence of
life
allows the emergence of multicellularity
and then from more information
processing building state machines all
the way up however you could imagine a
situation if you had um i don't know a
neutron star or a sun or a ferromagnetic
loops interacting with one another and
these oscillators building state
machines and these state machines
reading something out in the environment
over time these state machines would be
able to literally record what happened
in the past and sense what's going on in
the present and imagine the future
however i don't think it's ever going to
be with within a human comprehension
that type of life
you